bonsoir pannonie merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors
prolongation à des restrictions sur les
arrivées du brésil et d'afrique du sud 1
pour vous en espagne plus que nécessaire
mieux vaut tard que jamais selon vous
alors je pense que ça risque quand même
nécessaire bosse pas d'abord les garder
cette direction pour certains souche qui
passe il coulait qui pourrait peut-être
pas complètement protégées par les
vaccins correctement je pense que pour
le moins ça reste quelque chose de plus
prudent est-ce que c'est déjà trop tard
pour le moment il n'y a pas de ce type
de variants présents sur le territoire
espagnol de pas normalement alors et on
a eu très peu de circulation pour le
moment donc je pense que c'est encore un
bon moment pour lever certaines
restrictions éviter que ce soit dit
seigner d'une façon très lâche alors
évidemment vous vous êtes en première
ligne depuis des mois dans l'unité
qu'ovide à l'hospital clinic de
barcelone
comment qualifier la situation sanitaire
actuelle
alors c'est vrai que moi je peux parler
de la situation en catalogne qui est pas
forcément la même dans tous les pays
puisqu'ils avec l'indifférence sein des
différents comités autonomes mais c'est
vrai que maintenant on avait peur de la
dénomination des cas après après pâques
ce n'était pas le cas
en tout cas un cavalier d'amour
l'hôpital donc on reste situation quand
même qui était ce pour le moment mais
mais qui a pas énormément et je les
appelais afritac donc pour le moment la
situation n'est pas si mauvais qu'on
attendait donc la levée possible de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire le 9 mai ça
vous semble plutôt raisonnable vous êtes
pour en tant qu infectiologues
alors je pense que c'est raisonnable au
niveau national mais après ça dépendra
de communiquer en temps de faire les
messieurs qui sont les plus adéquates
pour la situation épidémiologique locale
c'est à dire on ne sait pas très bien
encore ce qui va se passer en catégorie
c qui vont connaître la décision de ces
autorités
quant à l'homme pour la continuation
après neuf mais on sait qu'il ya tant
région dans les pays en espagne et ou
sexuel qui va falloir continuer avec des
restrictions telles c'est important
parce que les taux de transmission sont
encore je pense que c'est rationnel
terminé le situation c'est état
d'urgence au niveau du pays
mais c'est quand même très important de
prendre les mesures adéquates à chaque
communauté autonome par rapport à la
situation locale alors en espagne plus
de 25% de la population devrait être
vaccinée pour lever justement ces
conditions ça vous semble assez 25% de
la population
je pense que c'est un peu ça avait quand
même j'aime aller un peu plus mais ça
valait calais on est maintenant très
très délétère
il faut chercher situations on puisse ne
pas pénaliser trop les côtes économique
et les tourismes donc je pense que c'est
maintenant le moment pour accélérer la
augmenter un peu cette proportion de la
population qui vaccinent que les
arrivées à 5 millions de personnes qui
avaient complété le schéma de
vaccination mais moi je ne pense que
c'est encore trop faible je pense qu'il
faut vraiment des lamenter pour l'été
tranquille face télévisé l'été on le
voit on a quelques petits problèmes avec
le
le vaccin astrazeneca en france et
beaucoup de réticence cela s'ajoute la
pénurie uns des autres vaccins pour le
moment est ce que c'est la même
situation en espagne
ouais c'est pas les je pense que c'est
la situation partout parce qu'ils
avaient beaucoup d'heures de
l'information qui n'était pas correcte
la dissémination de l'information n'a
pas trouvé la situation sanitaire
je pense qu'il ya des effets secondaires
qui sont claires mais sont graves
ils sont très très rares on n'a
peut-être pas eu assé sécurité par
rapport à un message qui ont dressé vers
des sonorités ont je pense que cette
citation de la population ce n'est pas
quelque chose très bon mais aussi on n'a
pas encore une décision très claire et
simple autorité quoi faire avec les
jeunes car il suggère la première bosse
comment on va continuer à vacciner tous
ces gens changer parce que cette belle
citation ne sont pas très bon pour les
messages surnom de sécurité puis les
autorités concernées tant chez vous à
barcelone de 5000 personnes menée fin
mars son distance mais avec masques a
priori aucun signe de contagion aux kovy
détecter un mois après vous vous
attendiez à un tel résultat comment
comment on peut d'ailleurs se
l'expliquer alors je crois qu'il est
très bon mais c'était ils voulaient
s'entraîner sélectionneur parce qu'ils
savaient faire avant les antigènes côté
je sais pas si c'est la solution mais
c'est quand même peut-être une façon
d'avancer vers une certaine normalité
qui ça nous manque à tous je pense que
c'est une très belle expérience
par ailleurs j'entends je lui que j'ai
lu que un angle atterrissent à leur
répéter ça avec d'autres concerts aussi
je pense qu'ils m'ont l'expérience mais
pour le moment il faut rester prudent
avec les résultats parce que c'est une
expérience pilote on peut pas les
généralistes pour le mans
on entendait sur une chaîne française le
pdg de modern à nous dire hier que le
virus selon lui en tout cas ne
disparaîtrait pas et qu'il faudrait
désormais vivre avec être vaccinés
chaque année comme la grippe est ce que
vous en tant qu infectiologues vous
partagez cet avis
tout à fait je veux pas les
connaissances biologiques peut-être
nécessaire pour me prononcer d'une façon
100% sûr je pense que ça va être la cite
aussi un avocat ça va continuer à
circuler et à mon avis il va avoir les
issers en circulation de souche pour
lesquels on sait là pas forcément
complètement protégé effectivement je
sais pas si la publicité ça va être tous
les sens il va falloir faire des
vaccinations beaulieu je suis d'accord
alors vous allez peut-être mieux lotis
en espagne puisqu'il ya le laboratoire
ils prat qui est en train de fabriquer
un vaccin on imagine qu'il est très
attendu un vaccin donc 100% espagnole
ouais effectivement je pense que c'est
quelque chose de très important des
comme ça avec un action de plus même moi
finalement je pense que c'est pas si
important qu'il va produire les vaccins
mais d'avoir assez de doses pour tout le
monde c'est ça qui est le plus important
espérons que ça va être avec une
efficacité et une provocation de
l'anticorps très serré je pense qu'ici
les plus importants c'est maintenant
c'est de remonter la pression des
populations qui vacciner l'emportent
avec quel vaccin évidemment si on a
d'autres et qui va le prouver ici céline
clément respectivement
merci beaucoup au roi nomme rosio ni
médecins infectiologues à l'hospital
clinic de barcelone d'avoir été avec
nous en français dans le texte on vous
remercie